ford madame la ministre de l'emploi
vous avez mardi et tout à l'heure encore
sans sourciller repris la promesse de
l'inversion de la courbe du chômage
comment osez-vous encore depuis 2012 le
président de la république lui-même six
fois lors d'allocutions solennelle a
promis cette inversion aux français plus
de mille corps ce temps passé et la
promesse n'a pas été tenue
mais 2016 ne semble pas calmer vos
ardeurs communicante
seul monsieur macron dans un accès de
lucidité un peu cynique d'ailleurs
prononce avec un talent fou l'éloge
funèbre de votre politique en matière
d'emploi
je cite nous n'avons pas tout faire on
aurait dû agir plus vite plus fort avec
plus d'audace plus frontalement mais
dans quel monde vivez vous madame la
ministre
votre politique a fabriqué un million
cent mille chômeurs de plus là où selon
monsieur macro 24 pays d'europe sur 28
ont vu diminuer leur chômage il ya
bientôt quatre ans que vous êtes élu et
vous allez présenter en janvier prochain
le 14 ou le 18 une question urgente
il n'y avait pas urgence jusqu'à
maintenant vous nous annoncez encore
tout à l'heure un plan une réforme
audacieuse pour mars prochain c'est à
dire applicables en septembre mais vous
avez fait quoi depuis quatre ans vous
avez fait quoi
madame la mise oui la courbe du chômage
finir absinthe percée vous n'allez quand
même pas tuer les 28 millions d'emplois
que compte notre pays
mais le seul objectif honorable qui
devrait être le vôtre serait de rendre
les clés en 2017 avec moins de chômeurs
qu'en 2012 et ça vous savez que
l'objectif n'est pas tenable alors
madame la ministre
sauver ce qui peut l'être n'ajoutez pas
l'impudence des nouvelles promesses
disqualifié au désastre social que vous
avez créé et fait preuve de discrétion
travailler plus et communiqué -
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre manuel valls
allez s'il vous plaît
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
vous réponds monsieur le député parce
que votre question est précisément
polémique qu'elle vise à faire de la
communication et qu'elle ne formule
aucune proposition et c'est tout le
contraire de la ministre du travail
myriam el khomri qui est engagée plein
vous plaire pour cette bataille de
l'emploi
personne ici personne ici ne peut nier
vous comme nous que le mal
on sait ailier précisément à ce chômage
de masse dont si je puis dire nous nous
sommes accoutumés
depuis des années je pourrais et avec
quelle facilité le seul député vous
renvoyer au bilan de 2012 je pourrais
rappeler les anglais ou pelé celle de
nicolas sarkozy qui avait expliqué
qu'ils avaient expliqué lui même qui ne
serait pas candidat si le chômage
n'était pas diminué par deux alors pas
de leçons sur ce sujet-là de la lucidité
oui et la lucidité oblige
comme le disent et myriam el khomri et
emmanuel macron qu'il faut continuer à
tout faire pour l'emploi et pour
diminuer le chômage
jamais un gouvernement jamais n'avait
pris un tel engagement 40 milliards
d'euros pour baisser le coût du travail
pour venir en soutien aux entreprises et
notamment aux pme
jamais nous n'avons autant fait pour
l'innovation pour la recherche et aux
lieux en permanence mais c'est vos drôle
et je le conçois de critiques et rappelé
aussi ce qui peut marcher
emmanuel macron répondants il y a un
instant souligné combien également
l'image de la france ô combien
détériorer avait changé combien les
investissements étrangers aujourd'hui
dans notre pays sont en augmentation
mais il faut continuer parce que le
nombre de chômeurs
le nombre de chômeurs de longue durée le
nombre de chômeurs notamment jeunes sans
qualification oblige à une mobilisation
est plutôt plutôt que de chercher la
vaine polémique et les bons mots et vous
avez plein de talent monsieur le député
dans cet hémicycle pour cela plutôt que
de cela
mobilisons l'état mobilisons tous les
services de l'état
mobilisons les partenaires sociaux parce
que chacun a des responsabilités et y
compris le patronat parce que quand la
nation qu'on 140 milliards d'euros
chacun doit être au rendez vous et les
régions je suis en train de rencontrer
tous les présidents de région
les régions aussi des compétences en
matière de développement économiques en
matière de formation et d'apprentissage
et moi je suis sûr que sur ce type de
questions plutôt que la polémique plutôt
que le bon mot plutôt que les attaques à
l'égard d'un ministre c'est le
rassemblement c'est la bonne volonté
parce que nous le devons aux français
merci monsieur le premier ministre sa
parole et hamada ben non